Let's start with the first piece, which is going to be implementing a function
that looks up the IP. Let's look at our code.
Here is our code for ASCII Chan. It's not a lot of code--64 lines, it looks like.
Most of it is contained in this main page handler.
Remember the get function just called render_front, which is this function.
All render_front does is run a basic query to get the 10 most recent pieces of art.
This Google database object here renders front.html, which is my template that draws
that whole form and the 10 most recent arts.
The post function here grabs the title and the art work from the request,
and if we have both of them, creates a new art object and puts it in a database
and reloads the page by doing a redirect. Otherwise it draws an error.
What we're going to do is we're going to change our code like this.
I'll just kind of put in comments what we want to do.
We want to look up the user's coordinates from their IP.
If we have coordinates, add them to the art.
That's going to be our first phase.
Let's work on the first part of this. Look up the user's coordinates from their IP.
We're going to need a function. We'll go ahead and throw it at the top here.
We'll call this "get_cords," and this is the first function we're going to be implementing.
This is going to take an IP, and it's going to make a request to hostip.info.
That request is going to look something like this.
Here is our API documentation.
We're just going to take this URL, and we're going to paste it here.
We don't want to use their IP. We want to use any IP. That's the URL we'll be requesting.
We're going to be requesting this URL using URL obtuse.
Let's go ahead and import that. We're going to be parsing the response.
It's in XML, if you recall.
We'll verify that. We're going the parsing this XML using minidom.
Let's go ahead and import that.
We know how to make a basic URL request.
I'm going to show you a few things we do in the real world to be a little less error prone.
The first thing we want to do is we want to store the content
of the URL in a variable called "content.:
The we're going to load the URL.
We're going to urllib2.urlopen, like we've been using this whole time.
We're going to call read on that response.
Now, if this URL is invalid or that website is down, this is actually going to raise an exception
I happen to know what that exception is, so I will go ahead and--.
If there is URL error--I found this by trial and error when I was working on this the first time--
we'll just go ahead and return. There are no coordinates.
That's if somehow this service is broken.
Normally we might log this.
If we were making a bigger site, I'd probably put some logging in here so that
if I'm maintaining the site, I can see that the geocoding is broken for some reason.
For our purposes right now, we'll just return none, because we'll be watching it.
Then down here we can say if content--there is a chance that the page
is broken in some other way and we just get an empty response,
so we want to make sure there actually is content.
Then in here, we're going to parse the XML and find the coordinates,
which you are the lucky person who is going to write that code for me.
What I'd like you to do is implement this get_coords function.
It's going to take a blob of XML.
Here is an example chunk of XML that comes from that website that should work.
What this function should do is it should return the coordinates found in this XML.
Keep in mind the coordinates here are longitude-latitude,
and I'd like you to return a tuple of latitude-longitude.
You're going to have to reverse them.
If there are no coordinates in the XML--say, for example, we get a response
that looks like this--I changed the IP to 0, 0, 0, 0, and you can see the response here.
There are not coordinates in here. This is a case we're going to have to handle.
Because hostip.info is a free service,
and it only has the locations for IPs that people have entered.
It'd also be worth your while to go ahead and go to that site
and enter your location if it doesn't know it.
I'd like you to implement that function.
If it receives XML that looks like this, it returns the coordinates
in the proper order--latitude, longitude.
if it doesn't find coordinates, it just returns None. Good luck.